relationships and pop culture especially
romantic ones tend to be idealized so
because of that it often sets us up for
unrealistic expectations
unfortunately hi my name is Omar Torres
I'm a licensed clinical social worker in
New York and today we're going to be
talking about some of the most
influential romances in TV and movies
and how they impact relationships today
you had sex with another woman we were
broken up we were on a break but for all
I knew what could last forever that to
me is a break up in their relationship
they broke up and got together you
really want to make sure that any time
you get back together with the next if
that's what you decide that it feels
like a brand new relationship the last
thing you want to do is bring baggage
from you know round 1 round 2 round 3
into the current relationship I think
that sets that's gonna set the both of
you up for conflict and not healthy
conflict
Jack and Rose it is the quintessential
you meet someone and it's like a
life-changing life-altering love and
it's a young love and it doesn't get the
time that you wish it did get to
flourish not all love is meant to stick
around all that long to be honest with
you and and that's okay as long as
there's something that you can take away
from it it's still really really
significant and sometimes one of the
greatest things that you can do for a
loved one is to let them go which is
sort of how I interpret this scene she
had to let him go literally otherwise
she would die so hopefully that's not
the case for a relationship but
sometimes the best thing that you can do
for your beloved for yourself for the
relationship is to say goodbye look I
don't care if you don't want to talk to
me or not but please get up and fix my
breakfast
I need my Springs loosen you're gonna
pick my breakfast or not what you wanted
to do is starve to death
would you please so here we see a pretty
explicit example of gender roles with
Ricardo essentially demanding that Lucy
make him breakfast when he is up and
dressed so you know he can make the
breakfast himself but these were a sign
of the times so you know one thing that
I find really interesting is Lucy's
silent treatment
one of the questions that I'll ask
someone when I noticed them shut down is
what is the silence communicated and in
that moment Lucy might say I'm angry and
then I would have Ricky acknowledge and
affirm the fact that she's angry and
pissed off and to talk about like what
can I do to help make a repair some
people really do need a cool-down period
and that may have been what Lucy needed
which is also perfectly healthy
however Lucy would have to communicate
that need to Ricky what's he supposed to
do you're flying around here which
wouldn't be lying around if we weren't
making room because yours is lying
around you get more shine around
so that's one of my favorite scenes um
that show because it talks about how do
two people join together and how do you
negotiate the space that a relationship
takes up in your life what's important
to realize in relationships is that this
is all a process this isn't something
that happens overnight and that
negotiations and the rezoning of
boundaries is something that again is
like a puzzle piece it's not something
that you necessarily figure out right
away don't you ever just shut up the
fact that at some point they knew this
argument needed to stop because it was
only escalating it's like wow music to
my ears sorry so one of the things that
I love about Harry Met Sally is that
it's one of the few rom-coms of its time
where the two protagonists meet and
develop a friendship over decades before
they ever get together and one of the
things that patients talk about in terms
of meeting someone is that like
lightning strike
choir singing fireworks like I know this
is the one oftentimes relationships are
a slow burn usually you meet someone and
you simply ask yourself do I want to see
them one more time and if the answer is
yes you see them one more time and then
you ask that question again and
eventually you ask that question over
months and you find yourself saying oh
yeah like I'm in a relationship with
this person and I want to build a life
with them and oftentimes that's how it
works and that's totally fine - it's
something that grows and develops over
time what I'm saying is and this is not
a come-on in any way shape or form is
that men and women can't be friends
because the sex part always gets in the
way of course they can be friends I
think what's important for the two
individuals is to suss out friendship
feelings and room
it's just afraid if you saw the kind of
people I came from you wouldn't have be
anywhere near me see that's where you're
a dummy
I think about what you grew up listen
and I look at what you are makes me
proud the reason why I particularly love
this scene in this relationship is that
Tara gives voice to something that I
think a lot of us have going on in the
back of our heads which is if I show you
the worst parts of me will you still
love me
I love willows responds instead of
saying how could you think that you know
I love you she says listen knowing where
you're from makes me all the more proud
of who you've become and what a great
way of saying I accept all of you I
accept the parts of you that you don't
like I accept the parts of you that
you're not thrilled with because
relationships are in Alucard I'm gonna
choose this I'm gonna like this and the
rest I don't really want we're all super
super complicated we all come from
histories that sometimes we're not super
proud of and finding that person that
says hey tell me everything there is to
know about you tell me about you and
I'll be here is one of the most
important messages that you can share in
a romantic in any relationship actually
ultimately we all want to feel loved we
all want to feel connected and don't be
afraid of you know your epic love story
maybe being a unique one
you
[Music]